[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another edition of wtr aka
[Music]
this is where we look at TV shows that
may be forgotten by some but remembered
by others were just how strange they
were but that's it let's talk about a
couple of characters called Sam and Max
though technically getting their start
as a comic sam and max became big names
at the height of LucasArts game success
in 1993 with Sam and Max hit the road it
was funny quirky and many would argue
ahead of its time but despite its
friendly look Sam and Max was mostly
meant for adults so it was kind of hard
to figure out where exactly to place
them for future projects or even how it
was hard for adult audiences back then
to get into a fluffy rabbit and a cute
dog it was also hard for kids to get to
those cuddly characters wearing up a
storm
well ok the parents the kids would
probably find it and the crowning
achievement of it came out on Fox kids
with Sam and Max freelance ponies
[Applause]
[Music]
kind of like small wonder this was a
very bizarre show to get a handle on not
to say that the game didn't have it's
weird moments but it still had a mostly
flowing narrative with our heroes trying
to solve a problem with freelance police
it always start out with an idea for a
flowing narrative but then be railed
into something more similar to say Monty
Python's complete waste of time does
anyone remember that does anyone
remember them most of the episodes start
off with the mission from either their
faceless Commissioner on the phone yes
affirmative Roger Miller
leather maker gadgets simply known as
the geek secretary Jena I'll look into
that
ozone thing right away oh great did the
problems were usually resolved by the
end but it clearly wasn't the focus the
focus was to partake in a lot of
fast-paced sir realism and honestly it's
so fast and so surreal that it's hard to
even know if you're supposed to laugh at
it half the time so does that make it a
bad show or good show I really don't
know it's so strange and hard to get a
grasp on that even years later you can't
tell whether it was behind its time or
ahead of its time just listen to how
they talk occupation just pummeling
vaporous anomalies in sensible officials
be colorless Lana's voice that kind of
dialogue goes on throughout the entire
series that vocabulary is way too
advanced for a lazy kid show there's
clearly intelligent people behind us but
then some jokes would be built up so
much and seemingly go nowhere that's
especially funny it was someone mutt
unlike the Commissioner with all the
intolerant in tones of the Commissioner
who sounded remarkably like the geek and
therefore could very well have been the
geek you have a long black hair growing
right out of your nose now am I supposed
to react to that are we supposed to
laugh because it's so funny or left
because it's so not fun
if that the whole idea of the show that
some jokes worked but others are just
kind of trolling us the speed of the
dialogue goes by so fast that's
legitimately hard to tell and don't get
me wrong some jokes are definitely
trying to get away with more than most
kid shows do prison showers I think it's
best if they keep their mouths shut but
what exactly does that prove we know it
has smart writers so why is it so tough
to figure out that's good or bad part of
it is that the world that creates is odd
but not a total descent into surrealism
either
for example the geek is a teenage girl
living on her own but they don't ignore
that they bring up that it's a weird
thing that she doesn't have any parents
around is your mommy home and my mommy
didn't call you I did but then they
don't really do anything crazy or funny
with it either so it's still kind of a
strange mix to comprehend what kind of
feel or environment is this trying to
make I try so hard to figure out this is
the work of genius madness or both
remarkable from inside and I started to
realize it reminded me a little bit of
Animaniacs which also had plots that
seemed more focused around just telling
jokes so I asked myself what did
Animaniacs have that made it more
relatable than saying the max had the
answer suffering I still stand by all
comedy is based on some form of misery
and even though the Warner's are happy
and zany characters they're still
confronting someone who is going to
suffer for their antics Sam and Max
rarely has those characters it's usually
just them working off of themselves and
enjoying it it's not a smart one or a
dumb one or a mean one or a nice one
they usually seem kind of on the same
page once in a while they come across a
foil that gets smashed or verbally
assaulted but for the most part it's
just these two acting like nothing
really hurts them touch a beautiful spot
I almost hate to leave meet you Sam but
let's do before we stop blubbering like
newlyweds over its grandeur you crack me
up little buddy even other similar
surreal shows like earthworm jim or the
tick still acted like they had something
to lose either they or the people around
them were invested in things not going
wrong sam and max couldn't care if their
place went up in smoke or if they won
the lottery they'd be
bein strange no matter what we return
victorious looks like I'm wearing
polkadot jammies so with most of the
time nobody reacting to the insanity
that's going on does it still work as a
comedy because that seems like a big
part of the equation to leave out well
well clearly not for everyone I think
you can still make the argument yeah it
can kind of work even famous characters
that do work off the misery or confusion
of others still have a certain charm to
them about just how much they're in
their own world
they're so removed from what you're used
to that can actually put you the viewer
in kind of an awkward state and a lot of
times that can be funny I did a whole
editorial on this called why do we love
stupid so you can watch that to get more
an idea what I'm talking about
nevertheless you can have a funny setup
even if there's nobody's misery to work
off of in the show even if it means your
expectations is what they're working off
of but with that said that might be why
the show only lasted one season I'm not
saying at all that there isn't an
audience or even an especially
intelligent one I think you have to be
to follow all this but for the average
kid at the time this was just a little
too much to take in
the humor was so fast so confusing and
so strange that it didn't seem to find a
big enough crowd for another season it's
kind of like if you gave Ren and Stimpy
really intelligent dialogue it's just
not what audiences were looking for at
the time don't get me wrong the
Animaniacs talked to telogen a lot of
the time but nothing compared to this
level these free-floating amends headed
space deities are getting real tired and
on top of that 90% of the time somebody
was getting hurt or giving what was
coming to them most younger audiences
wanted silly without much thinking or
thinking without much silly and I'd be
lying if I said a lot of older audiences
aren't really like that too so this is
another one that's hard to clarify who
exactly would like it and who wouldn't
because it's so odd and quick but
doesn't focus that much on the suffering
angle it's hard to gauge the fanbase who
would enjoy it but that's part of what
makes it one-of-a-kind
it's different than any other show
that's tried something like this it has
more Anarchy than Animaniacs but more
vocabulary than Ren & Stimpy it's
complex but simple quick yet sluggish
stupid and smart all at the same time
it's not the game it's not the
it seems to just be its own unique thing
there's definitely people out there who
love comedy that can't be categorized
and sam and max freelance police is just
a little too strange not to be included
[Music]
I'm gonna stash your credit Guy remember
it so you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
but God John what are you doing I'm
playing a card game Doug card games card
games are on for temple no they're okay
now
hey remember cards against humanity' of
course I do I'm not a Nazi
well the magic cards against humanity'
except telling a story now
yes it's called fantastic storytelling
no it was created by my Jack a British
person I don't allow them in my stream
of consciousness that's why you're a but
but you at home don't have to be the
object of the game is to tell a story in
any surreal or disturbing way that you
want I love that and I love you how can
this game be purchased a camp what I
have no me without your help
just follow this link to figure out how
you can support the Kickstarter where
did you even learn about this because I
knew to find out what you just watched
simply click on the link below